SEPTEMBER AND AVOID A POSSIBLE
SHUTDOWN THIS WEEKEND.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL TELLS
US WHAT IS IN IT TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
>> ONE DAY CLOSER TO THE FRIDAY
NIGHT DEADLINE AND TOP
REPUBLICANS RECEIVED A CRITICAL
ENDORSEMENT OF THIS BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> LATE TODAY AFTER A DISCUSSION
WITH SPEAKER PAUL RYAN OR
MITCH McCONNELL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED OFF.
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
SEGMENT PRESIDENT SUPPORT OF THE
BILL BECAUSE IT INCLUDES MORE
FUNDS TO REBUILD THE MILITARY,
SUCH AS THE LARGEST PAY RAISE
FOR OUR TROOPS IN A DECADE, MORE
THAN 100 MILES OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE BORDER
WALL, AND OTHER KEY DOMESTIC
PRIORITIES.
CONGRESS DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR A
SNOW DAY WITH THE CLOCK TICKING
TO FINISH UP A $1.3 TRILLION
SPENDING PACKAGE.
>> I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE IT WILL
MEET A NUMBER OF VITALLY
IMPORTANT OBJECTIVES.
>> SOME OF THE FINAL PIECES PUT
THE PUZZLE TOGETHER, INCLUDING
$2 BILLION IN NEW MONEY FOR
SCHOOL SAFETY MEASURES, A
BIPARTISAN PROPOSAL TIGHTENING
UP BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
FIREARMS PURCHASES, AND
$1.6 BILLION FOR THE PRESIDENTS
BURGER WALL.
THERE'S ALSO $4.7 BILLION TO
ADDRESS THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
REPUBLICAN SUCCEEDED IN KEEPING
OBAMACARE STABILIZATION MONEY
OUT OF THE DEAL, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS A WIN ON
KEEPING THE GATEWAY TUNNEL
PROJECT BETWEEN NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY NEW JERSEY FROM BEING
GIVEN PRIORITY STATUS.
BUT LAWMAKERS WERE STEAMED ABOUT
HOW THE DEAL WENT DOWN.
LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
TOLD FOX "I THINK THE WHOLE
PROCESS SUCKS.
I THINK WHOEVER DESIGNED IT IS
NOT QUALIFIED TO RUN A FOOD
TRUCK."
HE'S NOT ALONE.
>> $1.3 TRILLION IN SPENDING AND
FOUR PEOPLE -- IT'S NOT A GOOD
WAY TO DO BUSINESS.
I HOPE WE CAN DO IT BETTER IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE IT'S JUST
DESIGNED -- IT'S NOT VERY
TRANSPARENT.
>> A FORMER HOUSE BUDGET BLAST
OF THE SENATE FOR CREATING THE
MESS.
>> WE PASSED THE APPROPRIATION
BILLS.
IT IS THE SENATE THEY CANNOT GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER AND REALLY
COME TO THIS FIGHT WHERE WE DO
THIS HUGE SPENDING BILL THAT HAS
NOT BEEN NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE
HOUSE MEMBERS AND THE SENATE
MEMBERS, BUT JUST A SMALL GROUP
OF PEOPLE.
>> TOP DEMOCRATS SIGNALED THE
RELIEF THAT IN THE FINAL HOURS,
THE IMPASSE SEEMS TO HAVE
BROKEN.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE WE ARE GOING
TO SHUT DOWN.
IF NECESSARY, GOD FORBID,
CONTINUING RESOLUTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT COMPLETED
THIS WEEK.
SPEAK WITH ARE LEADERSHIP PIPES
ON BOTH SIDES HOPING DEADLINE
PRESSURE WILL HELP PRODUCE A
RESULT.